good evening ladies and gentlemen
thank you for joining us for today's
webinar titled the beauty of good design
and its effect on sustainability
this event is presented by what is
designed in collaboration with the
ongoing
national vending gallery exhibition and
the design singapore council
the event is also supported by the
national design center and is part of
the national design center's
sustainability and design program lineup
for january 2021
i am c from white's design and we are a
collective of design students trying to
share more about the value of design
in today's context from a student's
perspective our aim is also to encourage
singaporeans to participate in the local
design scene
i will be your mcm moderator for today
before we proceed with the presentation
i would like to highlight a few
key housekeeping matters please be
informed that this webinar will be
recorded
during the webinar your audio will also
be on mute however
we welcome questions throughout the
session please keep your questions
coming in through the zoom q a function
when posting a question please do
identify yourself
and indicate if you'd like a specific
panelist to address your question
should you encounter any technical
issues please reach out to our technical
team through the zoom chat function
our program today will be as such we
will be starting the segment with dr
christian
before moving on to another segment with
mr hans
if you have any questions during the
webinar about either segments
do send them in using the zoom q a
function and we'll have a discussion
about them at the very end
just a quick introduction of our
speakers before we start dr christian
and mr hans are here with us today
dr christian is a designer and educator
and during this webinar
he will be introducing a rational
analytical approach
based on three interrelated dimensions
namely synthetic
pragmatic and semantic mr hans tan is
also a designer and
educator and he will be sharing more
about the collection of items
put together for topic number two of the
national vending gallery
which is based on his hunt for akai
household goods shops around singapore
over the years
now without any more delays let's
welcome dr christian please
thank you for this nice introduction
today i'm going to
talk about the syntactic pragmatic and
semantic dimension
this
[Music]
and method of methodology of
specific methodology in design has been
presented in my book
design for contemporary world a few
years ago
i start by quotation from one johannes
eton who was one of the major
lecturer at the bauhaus in 1920s respect
of the individual is the beginning at
the end of
all education because we are dealing
with design
and we are also developing the
personality and the individuality of
each of our students
so today i'm going to just talk about
the descriptive dimensions syntactic
pragmatic and
semantic so what is the benefit of
synthetic chromatic and semantic
analysis is what we call sps
is a way of saying good design leads to
very sustainable design decision it is a
holistic way of considering design
but sps first of all enhance structure
and sharpen the sense of observation
from three respecting
angel with ceno student downtown
everywhere
and they observe their environment this
methodology can be applied to
entire environment from a simple object
to the most complete design
we can analyze a simple jury design but
also some building
or some very very complex engineering
product
this also could this method the
methodology could be extended to service
design
each dimension i'm going to present
later that
does not exist individually but are
interrelated
this is very important so it's a kind of
trilogy
and this sps could be driven from
fundamental level
to the most complex professional level
it's the fact that we are developing
this sensor this observation
although to allow and hide the advantage
and disadvantage of the
respective product or project and
naturally
it's open some design opportunity and we
will see later that it
can be used also it could be used also
as a rational tool of communication
so it's a method of analysis but it's
also a method of communication
so let's move to the syntactic dimension
i'm going to introduce each dimension
and after i will show
some of course some key example so
syntactic dimension refers to a
scientific analysis of the physical
characteristic of each component of
product or project we take in
consideration
structure but also materials
the process of fabrication process of
construction
and the functional relationship between
the different component
of a product or architecture project in
one way it's a very
scientific it's a very rational very
engineering approach
everywhere so there is this is one of
those
characteristics of this approach
specifically
we present this analysis with some
exploit perspective
the emotional technical drawing we try
to identify the materials and their
characteristic
system of assembly of the component in a
product
or architectural project we take also in
consideration
some manufacture estimated manufacture
process
the cost of product or project
also very important and naturally we
highlight the advantage and disadvantage
from the syntactic point of view
of the respective product or building
i'm going to show here a few examples so
here we have a
scan of a button to open a
drawer storage
at the entrance of one hdb and here the
this is a very very fundamental
study done by one group
of one-year students and they
first of all identify the the system the
mechanism
with this perspective and the material
the dimension
they they also highlight some
advantage and disadvantage of the
respective product
from a syntactic point of view but of
course some this is a
very very basic level another example
here is stick
to play game we have here some explores
perspective
showing all the components on the left
side we have some
front and top view
and also some identification of the
advantage here the students highlight
the fact that the components are
individually replaceable but in term of
disadvantage they highlight also that
the fact that
the exposed metal shafts rust easily
it can be easily vandalized
since the components are easily taken
apart pragmatic dimension which is
something very important the primary
dimension refer to rational analysis our
product
work and how it is it is to be used
it's included first of all a study of
the use of the function
user interface and what we call
anthropometric
so it's necessary to give a definition
is a comparative study of the size and
proportion of the human body
if we go very deep and of course the
ergonomic
we try to decide to minimize physical
effort and discomfort and hence maximize
efficiency we take also in consideration
in this practice pragmatic dimension the
maintenance consideration
if the product is very very well
designed and we have to clean it every
day
the maintenance will be easy so this is
something because it's a direct
interaction with a human being
we need to provide photo drawing
ergonomic position and sequences we zoom
on specific ergonomic position to
highlight the
problem we try also if if the case we
are designing or we observe
one object completely knocked down that
means
say kd we
explain the process of assembly of the
product
and this can it's a perfect example is
the ekr product for instance which are
presented this way
and of course we highlight the advantage
and disadvantage from a pragmatic point
of view so let's take a look at some
example okay this little button have
already highlight here the student took
some photo of the different
uh sequences uh when we
opened this specific button
then we are like also the fact that the
student i like that the very
sharp angle of the
the respective button uh could uh hurt
your finger so this is one of the
of the elements that we could be uh
improved for future design for instance
another analysis of the stick here
and the students show how we use this
little stick
it's very intuitive there is many way of
holding because it's circular it's a
tri-strap
they highlight a certain number of
issues here for instance
when you use for a long time this motion
turns to all
after extended use slipper when hand
gets
sweaty too small for large and risk of
wrists
in the area of back shoulder stiffness
if only wrist
is is used friction between side of end
and control platform
so from that in the future design the
student is going to take those
issue in consideration and we try to
find some
solution so the observation and the
identification of the disadvantage of a
product in one way is a motto of
creativity
semantic dimension i think that this is
maybe
one of the key dimension of those of
this trilogy
usually i believe that the designer make
the break
not so much in terms of syntactic and
not only pragmatic
but mainly in term of semantic if i look
at the
top design piece of furniture since now
50 years it's more at the level of the
language that the
the design the the the break has been
done
so the semantic dimension in design
content refer to an analysis of the
three of those three main components
first the context is which the product
is supposed to be used
context is a very vapor for instance if
i if i'm
it could be if i'm designing a handle
for mcdonald's if i'm
uh or for the hired or very prestigious
hotel the context would be radically
different
it can be a cultural context it can be
industrial context
etc extracts all those elements related
to the context but
at the whole level the format that we
take in consideration in this analysis
the form analogy within effect
is a comparison between the product and
other objects that have similar form or
shape
features and which are often used to
explain the principle of concept
and maybe the most important one the
spirit or emotional
response evoked by the product in
general
so we present specifically photo and
drawing
illustrating the above component but
also
we ask the student to select some very
sharp keyword to qualify each photo or
drawing
so let's see some example here so here
for instance this
button is located at the entrance of
some hdb
or some office this is for the context
in term of form analogy some students
have seen some energy with some
switch or some solar panel
some staircase and in term of
spirit the key word who came to their
mind
is we know abstractive because there is
no is completely
flash impenetrable and it's secure
so naturally the advantage is
the student either identified the fact
that is give to the user a sense of
security
i'm not going to read everything but
there is some
camouflage appearance help limit pool of
user to internet
fuel but in term of disadvantage this
very very
cold appearance uh it might be uh
not so good for them so they they
believe that
we cannot fit this kind of button to
some other context such are they called
tropical oriental
let's see some of this a comment this is
a nice presentation of this uh
stick and the context is of course the
arcade where the
the teenagers are playing some carnival
the people who are using the target user
definitely
definitely the young generation in term
of uh
analogy there is something very fun some
analogy with the bubbles
edible quaint spherical and in term of
uh
spirit uh it's uh they have the feeling
that
is related to the speed the action
and also the rotation it
seems that in terms of advantage it's
completely complement very well
the environment and it's simple and
dynamic
but in terms of the disadvantage the
students think that
these designs is circular design
compromise to
something will look effective or
obviously very fun compromise the
economy
in in the introduction i mentioned that
the the
tactic pragmatic and semantic analysis
could be also a
rational tool of communication and
at the end of the exercise of some
button or
handle my student naturally i've
ever they've presented their their
project
using the same approach we have a
project here from
my former student olivia lee who is
currently
teaching in nus she has designed this
tape she has done some investigation i
think she visit
a different shop to understand
all the mechanism of a tape and she
tried to see how this mechanism could be
incorporated in her system
one of the characteristics of this
button is the fact that the the action
of the button
or the handle of the tape is from the
front part the place where the water
come from
so she have done also some pragmatic
analysis and she tried to
show clearly to to explain
how the user is manipulating the the
tape
how we close it by rotating it
and how we can use eventually some
alternative approach
so this
[Music]
syntactic pragmatic analysis is a
fantastic tool to communicate
an idea for competition for instance or
to communicate
with your client also to communicate
with some technician
or with some engineer to explain how the
product is designed
in a very rational way semantic analysis
the context of this step is obviously a
quite exclusive restaurant and bathroom
and toilet
in terms of form analogy she established
a parallel with some
ballerina this representation of
pinocchio and some kind of
craft which is using wood in terms of
spirit she finds some fun with this uh
some analogy here with this person
the key word are very interesting here
in sequel simple
spring and longing
let's move to another example um dance
issue is also teaching in nus
has designed this hunger will look like
almost like a bomb rung
quite original this is a year one
project just a quick
simple syntactic analysis where she
present quickly the section of this
hunger which is at the contrary of the
conventional hunger very curvy
very very generous in a in wood
quite exclusive can be used in plain can
made in a plywood silicon or
polyurethane the the prototype here
has been made in wood
in term of ergonomy she has done a very
very nice
drawing explaining how we can grab it
from different parts
but also how we can bring few pieces
together
and how the shape the is directly
related to the
the shape of the shoulder which receive
natural leader
the shirt
in term of context this is of course
mainly for some quite exclusive
she finds some analogy in demo form with
a spider
or with a later wine of this food
and in terms of spirit
she found that the elasticity this kind
of this is drop
for color is uh expressing this fluidity
of our product
okay so this is uh just a few examples
how this methodology can
help to understand the product
identify the different component the
economy of
one existing product the semantic but
also
how this methodology can help us to
communicate our own design
thank you thank you dr christian that
was a very insightful sharing about the
different ways we can analyze design
if there are any questions please feel
free to submit them using the q a
function
and we'll address as many of these
questions as we can at the end of the
entire session
so without further ado let's welcome mr
hanstein
so for today i'd like to share you know
about uh the sustainability of design
but using the framework that
dr christian has mentioned earlier the
pragmatic semantic and
synthetic analysis you know even for
myself i do use
uh this framework as a pedagogical
framework
to teach design and uh
for this framework it's really useful to
appreciate uh not just a good design but
also how design can be sustainable
in a different way so normally when we
talk about sustainability uh we often
focus on the synthetic part
of the product you know meaning you know
using materials that is
ecologically friendly using uh
production processes that's a
responsible
you know and synthetic also refers you
know to the type of technology that is
appropriate yeah to be used in a product
but at the same time uh it's also
interesting to
to think about uh sustainability in the
pragmatic point of view
because certainly you know performance
and usability does affect
uh sustainability and for example you
know
if a product you know is uh really uh
usable is really comfortable
uh one would expect uh a person or
customer or user to use it
uh far longer than a product you know
that spoils easily
or gets uncomfortable really quickly so
the other thing
is uh in the semantic point of view
we often see uh i might see semantic as
the idea of form
and also meaning form being you know the
shape and what's communicated through
the shape and the
form of the product by the same time
meaning is the
it's what we what we construct the
meaning we construct when we see
uh the product or the shape or the
details of the product and this is very
important you know if we push it to the
extreme
you know we could see you know for for
example the meaning that we have
constructed for
uh family heirlooms that we keep for a
long period of time you know uh
it's a very interesting uh perspective
of how we could
uh make our products last a lot longer
if we are able to create more
connections more meaningful connections
with our products so uh i think the
interesting thing about this
analysis the sps analysis you know is
that if you can see on my slides here
it's expressed as a venn diagram so at
the same time
i wanted to show you know that the
overlaps here
actually mean something it matters as
well and
in this case as you can see here if one
does not overlap the different segments
uh you might see
the the diagram as something like that
you know more like a segmented diagram
uh and one i would say that you know uh
for design that is segmented like that
you know it's a poorly considered design
and i'll give you an example so for
example you know if the company would be
designing a product
uh maybe in this case uh the
one person in a company you know uh
maybe the marketing manager determines
what
to design you know from a marketing
survey uh maybe the production managers
will suggest you know a material or
production process you know to produce a
product uh the engineer might come up
you know with a particular
use or utility to design for and in this
case maybe the engineer
or the designer you know will design you
know a look for it you know aesthetic to
cover the whole design
and all these decisions are made
separately you know as
as demonstrated by the venn diagram and
they do not come together
uh thoughtfully as a whole and maybe you
know
some you might end up with something
like that uh if
if you're owner of a whiskey uh mini egg
with uh
uh i'm sorry uh but i thought this was
an interesting example to show
you know how a design can components and
can be decided separately and when they
come together you know they
they might not seem to be well
established as a product as a whole
and in this case in the spirit of you
know using examples of household kitchen
tools
uh maybe i use a really much better
example so in this case you know
uh if you look at a mini risk as a
household product
one of the best rated products is the
one by kitchen craft
the professional magic mini whisker with
the soft grip
even in this uh example uh one might say
that a lot of
design decisions made here is made
separately so for example
especially in a synthetic point of view
or a pragmatic point of view
there's many components that are being
used you know to fulfill different
functions
so if you look at this professional
magic wiz you know it is made up of at
least
six different components you know even
just
with the handle alone there's four
different parts you know and uh
made up of different materials you know
the silicone being used as
probably a plastic core uh and a harder
plastic cap
uh so so these come together to to
fulfill the performance of the product
one might argue that you know this
product really uh achieves a good level
of pragmatic performance
you know but at the same time you know
just for the sake of today and
for some sick analysis you know i will
show you another product
a whisk a mini whisk as well you know
that has been honed by
ages of i would call it uh old wisdom
you know and
uh to demonstrate to you know what if a
whis was to be designed
or to make by overlapping all these uh
different spheres uh in the analysis so
uh
a good example of this certainly is the
bamboo with
the whisk used you know by traditional
uh in a japanese to uh waste katu from
matcha and uh here you know if you look
at the whisk and you know how it's
produced
it's really beautiful and it's
essentially made out of a single
uh segment of a bamboo you know and with
some strings
tying the prongs together and uh you
know in a synthetic point of view if you
follow the slide
uh you know one might say that you know
the choice of material
is really good here as well you know
it's waterproof bamboo is waterproof
uh naturally you know it's a neutral
material it doesn't add any extra flavor
uh to the beverage it's a renewal
material as we know
bamboo grows really really fast and in
this case
you know uh there's a very interesting
effective way of constructing uh this
piece you know if you watch
videos on youtube on the construction of
bamboo is you will see how the craftsman
is able to using
you know this uh this black string that
you see on the bamboo whisk
to tie and to separate the prongs
together right
and to separate them into the elements
that are open
and elements that are closed in the
middle to create this flower-shaped
dome like uh prongs of about 100 over
prongs you know
and with those prongs uh being really uh
small
and uh in a big multitude you can
actually whisk and froth
very very effectively and it's aided by
two types of
prongs actually you know the the wider
prongs whereas flexible
and thin and if if you notice the prongs
inside
is tied together on itself uh into a
stiff prong so when you whisk uh these
two prongs act together
and and to be able to enable you to
whisk the the
tea or the beverage in this case are
very very effective and you can create
from very very uh
quickly and of course you know there's
other advantages if you see this uh uh
just this single piece of bamboo as well
uh you might notice that it stands on
its own it doesn't need an extra stand
it doesn't need a hole
you know for it to be hung and uh and
the natural
uh note of the bamboo actually separates
the
the prongs and the handle you know
almost as if you know it was
intentional and uh semantically of
course one might say that you know
when you look at this on a table it
looks really structural
you know it looks organic and natural
and of course this has
now become a very very important
cultural you know part of
a japanese tea ceremony contextually
so you know with that uh i hope this
example gives you an idea of how
a product can be designed very
thoughtfully and very well in a very
well considered manner
you know with this framework of
pragmatics and meta and synthetic
coming together as overlapping uh uh
segments where a designer or person
designing or making a product can make
it
you know uh by not considering the
different factors uh
in and of themselves but consider them
as a whole and making
design decisions that solve different
parts
of the product at the same time and with
that
i also wanted to use this framework of
analysis to reflect on some of the
products that is
currently being featured at the national
vending gallery
and this gallery is currently presenting
topic 2
and it presents about 24 household items
and these household items uh
uh they're rather interesting because uh
they have been sourced
from very old household goods shop in
singapore
so over the past few years it's become a
hobby of mine over the weekends
you know could go to very arcade looking
uh household shops
some of them are still around some fill
with dusty
old shelves and look for hidden gems and
for cotton gems
of our small household products you know
and these products
might look simple at onset but they're
really wonderfully
and beautifully designed and in fact you
know if you look at the
framework here i might go further to say
that none of these products that's been
presented in
the national gallery because they're
really old and designed as a profession
maybe has not been established at that
time
50 years ago none of these products were
probably designed by a designer
you know these products were designed by
a mix of our different factors and
stakeholders coming together so for
example you know the producers
producing these products are might
really want to maximize you know their
profits
they find the most cost efficient way to
produce these products use the least
number of materials and at the same time
you know the distributors or the
shopkeepers want to maximize business
profitability
right so their selling price uh must be
considerably higher than the
manufacturing or the distributors price
and at the same time all these things
need to fulfill you know the
desire of the uh consumers for very a
quality
uh product uh product that at least
works fairly well
so you know so with that you know you
might say that you know these products
are designed by non-designers
you know honed by circumstances and the
context where it's made
in and make form and make four you know
by the same time when all these things
come together and optimize the product
you know using these circumstances uh of
course
the result can be really bad right yeah
but sometimes
when the stars are aligned you know some
products can be really really top fully
uh worked out as well and i really just
want to talk about a few of them
today so uh i will just be picking out
some of
the points of each product for you to
think about as well
so in this case you know the first
product i want to show is the map
and the map here if you notice
uh and if you look closely you can see
the very tiny pink dots in the mat right
they're scattered very neatly all over
so these pink dots are actually in fact
uh raffia string pink typical roughest
ring
that is used to tie the fabric together
to weave a floor mat
and these uh uh fabric that they use
probably
cotton off cuts from a waste material
you know from a fabric production
and coming together uh with the
reference screen woven in such a manner
to form a rock and in fact you know by
weaving in this way it forms a lot of
bumps
right and it does help you know create
texture
for the rubbing of one's feet when
drying uh next is uh
the frosted plaster cup uh you might
find this very familiar right you might
have used this in your school canteen
you know when you were really young and
the frosted feature in this cup for me
uh is really special
in some in a few ways you know number
one of course you know the frosted
texture here you know makes the
the plastic cup gives a non-slip texture
you know so that you can hold it
uh more easily than one which is really
smooth
but at the same time uh this actually
makes the cup a lot less susceptible
to scratches and even if you scratch it
it kind of hides the scratches
you know so so it gives the cup a lot
more longevity i might think you know
compared to a clear
plastic cup which is very hard to
maintain and last but not least
you know having this frosted texture on
the cup
it actually looks a little bit like
condensation you know when you when you
put cold water
in a drink and it gives the impression
you know that the intrigue inside is
cold
and for me that's that's that's a really
interesting point you know the next
product uh
i like to share is the tong and uh of
course you know you can find many tongs
in
in different uh household goods and uh
but this particular one for me is
really really uh well designed in this
aspect
as you can see you know this tong does
not use a spring system as most uh
modern tongs found in the marketplace so
the hinge here depends entirely
on the flexibility of the metal part
that you see at the hinge right using
the material property as a spring
instead of
having spring systems to fulfill the the
clasping motion
yeah at the same time if you notice in
the middle of of the tongue
right here you have the edge folded
and also there's an indentation the line
of indentation here so essentially these
details actually stiffen
the part of the handle where you hold it
and you apply pressure
and last but not least at the end of the
tongue you get a scalloped tip
you know that helps you whole food you
know but in this case you know when it's
done really
yeah well uh it looks really beautiful
at the same time uh the next product
here is
the electric shaver and which some of
you might recognize this
this was the first electric shaver i had
when i needed to shave
and this table still in production is
really cheap you know because it's made
out of a very
simple straightforward uh plastic
molding uh techniques
yeah but at the same time you know the
shape of this uh shaver is really
interesting
it separates clearly the handle from the
shaving element
and you know if you imagine holding it
switching it on with your fingers
and using it it actually is very
comfortable to use and
almost a very elegant way you know to
use a
shaver which is quite commonly uh you
know quite a industrial
uh looking product uh next
is a sauce dispenser uh i'm not sure if
you've seen this before in some
of the really old shops but in this case
this sauce dispenser
is made of just a single material unlike
most sauce dispensers you see nowadays
where it's made of different materials
you know probably some
plastic you know with a silicon lining
but in this case the body the base
the handle the spout is all made of a
single clear plastic material that's
molded
in one go and the interface between the
cap and the mouth is roughen
here for a friction fit a very simple
fit and
uh and more importantly for me you know
when it's done this way not only you
know does it save on resources
and well when the whole thing is clear
when it holds the colored sauce
it almost looks like the sauce is being
suspended inside this clear receptacle
and it really looks beautiful
you know with with a colored sauce
inside the next one
uh is a measuring jar and this measuring
jug
looks pretty normal and it is uh made up
of a rather thick gauge of steel
but more importantly you know it has a
wider mouth and a spot to clearly
indicate
whether whether the liquid is going to
come out uh in this case you know the
volume readings usually is printed
but the volume readings in this case is
embossed
on the inside of the measuring jar and
you can see it quite clearly
at the same time you know it doesn't
require the extra step to put the
readings
that's often printed on typical
measuring jugs but if you notice here
there's a really interesting
thing about this job it's the inverse
handle so in this case the handle was
not
attached wrongly yeah to the jug but it
was intentionally inversed
uh in in the shape so that you know when
you inverse the handle like that
it actually makes it a little bit more
gives you a little bit more control when
you handle it especially when
the jug is uh heavy or when you when
it's quite full
you can you can you can pour it and you
can use it now with a little bit more
control
so i thought that was a very very
thoughtful uh feature
the next product i'd like to show is the
wave cutter
uh some of you might not know what this
is for essentially the wave cutter
is used to cut our pastry and cakes for
example like
you know uh so that you know you get a
wavy uh shape at the edge of the agar ga
when you cut it
and in this case it's it's as simple as
it can get
and essentially this wave cutter is made
out of single material
single thickness uh it's folded uh sheet
pattern you know for for the cutting
edge
and it's locked directly into a folded
profile that's made of the same
thickness
and the same material so it holds it
like a clamp
for me it's very very intelligently
designed and produced
right although it looks really really
simple
the next product i'd like to share is
the mark with the saucer lid
you know these marks are made of
melamine and we see a lot of mana mine
wares
and coffee shops that's being used
because melamine is a very cheap
material but at the same time very
durable plastic
right but at the same time for me this
mug is unique because of
the use of the saucer so the saucer as
you can see here
it has two different circumferences so
the bot the top of the saucer you know
acts as a saucer when you place a cup on
it but when you when you flip it over
and you cover the cup
it sits nicely over the cup as a lid as
well
and i thought that was quite thoughtful
at the same time you know
it just happened that these colors
that's being produced really look
beautiful when it comes together
uh the next thing is it's uh a
deep-fried thermometer
you might not have seen this before i
would consider this
more of an antique piece because
nowadays you know uh thermometers are
maybe steel probes right and you can
insert them in
different types of temperatures and also
different types of food material
but in this case uh this deep-fried
metal was probably uh made
20 30 years ago where we don't have
probe thermometers
and to be able to insert the thermometer
directly into hot oil
you know to measure the temperature of
hot oil for deep frying
this was quite smartly uh done whereby
existing community meter is essentially
placed
in a glass enclosure as you can see uh
in a picture
so it's a glass tube thermometer within
another glass tube
and uh by doing that you know it's a lot
safer and
less risky you know when you put it in
an oil with a very very high temperature
and uh you know if it breaks inside you
know at least it won't contaminate the
food by the same time i thought it's
interesting you know that you know the
graphical representation of readings
are very clear and precise at the same
time you must be wondering
you know why is that this great not on
the clip of the thermometer
and for me you know i was wondering
actually why is it there for you know is
it
just for decoration it couldn't be and
uh i i postulate that it's there
to serve as a warning you know to serve
as a sign because when you insert the
thermometer
into a pot of hot oil it serves as an
indicator to show you that there's
something that you know popping
up visually you know still that you for
example you wouldn't cover
uh the cover of the port you know
accidentally and you know
breaking the thermometer so i thought
that was really smart as well
at least for times as such and last but
not least the last item for me and
really beautiful item
simple as well is the net scrub this is
this
is essentially a sponge a scrub that you
can use to wash
dishes it's made out of fishing net so
fishing net as we know is extremely
strong
and extremely durable but by you know
scrunching them together in this shape
uh and tying them together it forms many
interacting holes
so it can hold soap very well at the
same time it can be used to scrub grime
pretty well as well and more importantly
you know unlike some of the
more resilient sponges it will not
scratch utensils
or crockery you know for example it's
made of clear plastic or glass
so it's really gentle on my utensils but
at the same time it can
take off the grime pretty well and uh
i'm not sure uh if you heard this
before you know from your grandparents
you know my grandma told me once and
once one of the best
ways to clean and most efficient ways to
clean dishes
is to use a cloth instead of a sponge
because if your cloth is a very big
surface area
and you can wipe and clean with soap and
covering you know the dishes that you're
washing and
sometimes you know you can wash your
dishes and half the time you know
compared to using a sponge
so in this case you know using a net
scrub you actually get a much bigger
surface area
and and thus uh it's probably more
efficient to use this
you know to clean your dishes as well uh
so so with that
i end uh my presentation and you know i
hope if you have time
to visit the exhibition at future pass
at the national vending gallery at the
national design center and we have
14 more objects there for you to think
about and for you to consider
and with that and my presentation thank
you very much thank you hans for the
insight for sharing as well so now we'll
be moving on to the q a
segment so we actually have a question
for dr christian
and the question is what are some ways
we can increase the semantic factor of
our design
thank you very much for this question
because it's uh
it's absolutely uh crucial for me i
would like to say that the inspiration
of the designer is not coming
especially from design it can it should
the designer
should observe their environment if you
look at the top masterpiece in
there since now more than 50 years
some sorts of inspiration come from
nature come from
arts come from food
and a designer is one a student in
design she won't
be one person who like food who like to
drink
we like to meet people who like to
observe
who go to museums and uh who like
dance dance for instance it could be
also a source of inspiration
music it should be a source of
inspiration
and uh it's uh we of course we can get
some some inspiration from a
famous uh design from famous designer of
of course
but the the the for me the most the
purest
inspiration for for a designer is when
it should come from everyone or everyday
life
and sometimes ugly object could be
source of inspiration and could be
twisted in such a way
that and could touch the scale can
change
uh just to finish this presentation um
when i was doing my study in finland i
was studying at the university of art in
art and design in helsinki uh and one of
the top designer at this time was stefan
lee
force stephanie's force is a bit older
than me
and he was fascinated by the insect so
his source of inspiration was insect and
so
from the scale of a small microscopic
insect he could bring and change bring
some character and make a
table or chair from those specific
articulation
so i would like to conclude that from
absolutely everywhere
from absolutely any scale you can be
inspired
and bring back to your own design uh
thank you for the answer
uh and also because we are running a bit
late we'll try to do one more question
yeah so be directed to both the speakers
so the question
would be at what point do you know that
you have over analyzed or over designed
something
especially when it comes to everyday
items which are
meant to be mass produced at relatively
low cost
i think how can staff will be
please now that's a really good question
actually uh
i guess that's a question that a
designer will ask uh at every step of
the process
when especially when you're designing a
product that's supposed to be
economically uh produced
and sold at a relatively low cost
and uh so i don't think i think in this
case uh
if we are talking about optimization but
it's a matter of
give and take so uh you can't
you can't usually over analyze something
you know but but once you have come up
with the product
you know sometimes uh uh
you might have you know because you
wanted to achieve you know
you know a certain low cost for example
you might have given up on some
uh some a different part of the and if
you know if you use the analysis
yeah the christian provost you might
have given up a little bit on usability
for example
you know you might have made a
compromise on a different aspect of the
product
yeah so for me although optimization
you cannot over optimize something
because you know if you over
optimize something it's still optimized
right it's just very very optimized
but at the same time yeah you know uh
with limited
uh materials limited products you know
limited technology
uh and while we work with what we have
you know it's always you know about
coming up with that
uh uh that balance you know optimization
where you consider all the different
parts together
so that you know contextually your
product works you know for
your end user i would like
to add that to design a very simple and
inexpensive product is one of the most
difficult
challenge for designer it's almost
if i want to find some poetic analogy to
write
a long letter or to write a poem and to
try or to write a song
and we try to throw away not necessary
were to keep only this sense
and uh we never over analyzed i would
like to say that
we this syntactic pragmatic and semantic
analysis allowed us to look at the
product from a
three different angle which is very uh
practical very very very very important
for us
but we we can spend a lot of time and
more we observe
and then we are light some problem more
we can find some solution
but regarding the uh
the the the if we look at the top
masterpiece again
you you observe that there is nothing
unnecessary
everything is there and all i'm so happy
that
hans highlight all those projects object
presented in the exhibition uh it remind
me also after the summon war
in japan some people
who are not designer have been using the
motor
of the old car to make some spoon
and there is one exhibition of of the
alexander van der jacques
vegeta from the vitra design museum
showing all those beautiful
humble objects using the minimum
materials
but we did not sacrifice
the the pragmatic dimension
so i hope i answered your question
uh thank you speakers for the answers uh
and
yeah once again uh we're so sorry that
we're running a bit late
uh for the rest of the q a questions
that are unanswered we'll try to
answer them and we'll be sending a
concluding email at the end
in a few days time so do look out for
that so
yes we also like to thank all of you for
joining this us this evening and we hope
that you have gained some interesting
insights
should you wish to revisit any
presentation the recording of our
session will be made available online
on design singapore's youtube channel
you may also visit the national design
center to experience the national
vending gallery for yourself
national vending gallery is an unmanned
gallery that introduces and vents
temporary collections that reveal
the multi-fold influence of design
gripping our lives
our second topic future pass exhibits
enlightening household artifacts that
are sensible and beautiful
at the same time though having clearly
been around for a long time these
artifacts provide an uncanny perspective
to the future of democratic design
the topic will be ending on 7th february
so do drop by before then
what is design is also holding an event
in conjunction with national vending
gallery
we are having an open call for some
missions of images from people with
everyday items that they feel like have
been very well designed
three lucky winners will be chosen to
receive a nail kit plastic scoop and a
wire scrub respectively
all of these are part of the 24 selected
items on display at the national vending
gallery so do scan the qr code or submit
your photos to the what is design
instagram page
lastly we really appreciate it if you
could complete a simple survey for the
workshop
to help us improve our future programs
you can do so by scanning the leftmost
qr code
or by assessing the link that we'll be
posting into the zoom chat right now
and if you would like to find out more
about the various upcoming programs at
the national design center
do scan the qr code that you see in the
middle
finally as much as we cannot see
everyone in this virtual space
the sharing the lively discussion and
the energy is real
thank you for sharing your evening with
us it has been a pleasure hosting this
webinar
with this keep well stay safe and have a
very pleasant evening
goodbye
you